مبروك أن أراكم ،
لقد رأينا هذا الأسبوع
تمر بمجموعة كاملة
من المشاعر ،
يمكنك حتى البدء في تلخيص
الأيام القليلة الماضية
[موسيقى]
حسنًا ، الحقيقة أنه من الصعب أن أصف
الكلمات التي اضطررت إلى التعبير عنها  عشت خلال هذا
الأسبوع
، كان من الصعب حقًا ما حدث
مع برشلونة
وداعًا بعد أن كنت هناك
طوال حياتي في مكان واحد
وبعد ثلاثة أيام دون أن أنسى
ما حدث ،
تغير كل شيء
كنت أعيش مع الكثير من الشك والكثير
من الأعصاب وتوقع الكثير من ذلك
سيحدث هذا وكثير من الإثارة والرغبة
في البدء ،
لقد كان وصولًا خاصًا حقًا
الترحيب من الأشخاص الذين رحبوا بي
والذين خرجوا إلى الشوارع ،
أنا متحمس جدًا لبدء هذه الحقبة
الجديدة وسأذهب إلى
عش وأنا مستعد لبدء حياتي الجديدة هنا
في باريس ،
لقد فزت بألقاب الدوري ، وفزت بلقب دوري الأبطال ،
لكن هذا جديد بالنسبة لك ، هل أنت مستعد
للحياة حيث أن الرجل الجديد في غرفة الملابس
هو
[موسيقى] ،
نعم  أنا على دراية
بخلفيتي والهدف الذي يقاتل به هذا النادي
لفترة من الوقت للفوز بدوري أبطال
، وقد اقترب
مني في السنوات القليلة الماضية على المستوى الشخصي ، وأود
أن أفوز بدوري أبطال آخر
كما قلت.  في السنوات
السابقة وأعتقد أنني جئت إلى المكان
المثالي الجاهز لذلك
لدينا نفس الأهداف التي حصل عليها النادي من
لاعبين رائعين أحد أفضل
الفرق في العالم
وإن شاء الله يمكننا تحقيق هذا الهدف
الذي يريده باريس كثيرًا.  أريد
الكثير ونأمل أن نتمتع به مع
سكان باريس أيضًا ،
ما هو الهدف ، ما هو النجاح بالنسبة لك
هنا
جيدًا بصراحة ، أنا أعيش يومًا بعد يوم أفكر في
الاستمتاع بغرفة الملابس حيث
يوجد الكثير من الرجال الذين
أعرفهم  الأصدقاء هناك الذين يشبهونني قلت من
بين الأفضل في
العالم أعرفهم وأكون قادرًا على الاستمتاع
باللعب معهم حتى أكون قادرًا على
تحقيق الأهداف التي يمتلكها النادي
والقيام بكل ذلك بطريقة مريحة
والسير ببطء أحب  لتكون قادرًا على الاستمرار في
الفوز  الألقاب والقيام بذلك هنا في
فرنسا للقتال من أجل كل شيء
أعتقد أن هذه هي الأهداف
وآمل أن يحدث
ذلك هل سمحت لنفسك
بالتفكير في احتمالية مباراة باريس سان جيرمان ضد برشلونة في
دوري الأبطال
[موسيقى]
، فقد يكون الأمر غريبًا
بالنسبة  إذا حدث
ذلك من ناحية ، فسيكون من
الرائع العودة إلى منزلي مرتديًا قميصًا مختلفًا ،
لكننا سنرى ما سيحدث في المستقبل
، وإذا حدث ذلك ،
فسنستمتع به أيضًا